une grosse journée aujourd'hui à la
commission charbonneau vous allez voir
la paix syndicale sur les gestions des
chantiers ça s'achète et parfois à très
fort prix isabelle l'homme que l'on voit
serge larouche il est président de
ganotec une entreprise de construction
est venu dire qu'il a dû arroser alors
que ça a été payant pour un chef
syndical
oh oui qu'on connaît bien d'ailleurs ma
famille est là bien que les que oui euh
oui absolument qui est un tout puissant
leader syndical qui est partie seulement
en novembre dernier alors vraiment
succession de révélations aujourd'hui de
la part de ce monsieur larouche qui a
raconté combien ça peut être difficile
sur des chantiers quand on n'avait pas
le local 144 de son côté social local
qui était gérée par gérard cyr
ils vont envoyer de la main d'oeuvre
expliquez-moi isabelle qui n'est pas les
véhicules pour non voyant qu'il y ait de
l'international où l important de le
dire
le conseil provincial des métiers dès la
fin des années 90 les dirigeants de
ganotec ont dit à monsieur larouche que
c'était plus facile avec gérard cyr
quand on le payait alors on lui donnait
des pauvres est en argent comptant sur
des chantiers et là ça se passait
toujours mieux dans ce temps-là et
l'extrait que j'ai choisi il donne un
exemple monsieur larouche où il a été
prévenu lui qu'il fallait donner 40
mille dollars à monsieur c et il le
laissait faire pour avoir la paix serait
comme une garantie écoutez bien je
t'aime beaucoup et je me suis podomètre
objecté peut-être que j'ai vu c'est aux
communes une assurance pour pas se faire
frapper
après les événements de baisse qui vient
où une une police ou une protection un
peu comme ça se passe dans 90% des bas
au québec
c'est c'est une autre époque on a
l'impression qu'on nous décrit or c'est
fait pas très longtemps
on ne sait pas si gérard si regardez
tout cet argent là pour lui ou le
distribuer à ses amis enfin l'histoire
le diplôme score le disent pas encore
mais il ya pris pas mal d'argent
ayant appris énormément l'histoire qui
suit encore plus grosse gérard cyr
figurez-vous alors qu'il est à la tête
du conseil provincial a exigé de ganotec
qui elle lui verse un pourcentage sur
des contrats que la compagnie décroché
avec des raffineries des contrats
payants et ils soutenaient qu'ils
avaient droit ce pourcentage le parce
que c'était grâce à lui que ganotec
avait décroché des contrats alors la
compagnie a d'abord dit non évidemment
et puis pour une raison qu'on ignore
sans doute pour que ça aille bien dans
les raffineries sur les chantiers eh ben
on a fini par céder et coutellier 1 puis
2 millions représentent la somme qui est
connotée converser à gérard entre 98 est
allé jusqu'à fait 2006 qui est ce que
prisé note sur ce document ce c'est mon
écriture
alors je peux vous dire que serge
larouche a dénoncé a alerté dès 2005 la
ccq la commission de la construction du
québec le ministre du travail de
l'époque laurent lessard de tous les
problèmes qu'il avait avec le à 444 on
lui a dit monsieur là sans lui aurait
dit gérard du 144 on peut pas touche à
ça et plus tard il a parlé aussi
ministre whissell qui lui lui a dit
j'aime pas ce que j'entends il a appelé
gérard cyr et il lui aurait dit gérard
j'aime pas ce que j'entends mais
manifestement ça a pris jusqu'en
novembre dernier pour comme monsieur
circuite le la 440
mais ils l'avaient donc dénoncer à une
période où absolument
bon bah merci isabelle gros aujourd'hui
lasser les mamadou issoufou est ce pour
ça s'annonçait pas comme ça mais c'est
comme ça que ça s'est déroulé ben voila
merci a dit au revoir